[Music]
the guard you know my you know my ways
the path here know me better than I know
myself
and you've known me longer anyone knows
such knowledge is too wonderful I can't
even understand such knowledge is too
wonderful
I can't even comprehend this you see I
make miles the deaths when I see you so
good it fine I'll be lost in the middle
of your love
[Music]
my world is shaking your hand won't be
still the word even where our world is
saved
[Music]
you're fearfully
hello table friends welcome we're so
glad that you guys are with us tonight
and excited to have you joining us in
this way
we hope that you guys know that you're
loved and you're valued and you are
prayed for and wanted as part of our
table community we hope that this is a
meaningful time for you guys as we join
online together we're gonna get started
with a meditation tonight and I just
hope that you guys will join in with us
as you're able to be quiet for a moment
settle in to whatever swirls around you
listen to the sounds feel each texture
against your skin notice where your
thoughts are ready and let yourself feel
the emotions and feelings that you've
carried here
[Music]
notice your breathing as you take this
breath let it root into this moment you
cannot return to a path nor can you
clean a future liner before it's needed
you have only the breath you need for
right now it continues the flow in and
out your attention without your request
regardless of your situation in the same
way the grace of God music with each
breath his faithful presence available
to us regardless of our surroundings our
struggles as you take each choose his
love let it reach you into the present
invite it to fill up your lungs and roll
out of your body in your mind
it's your life you are full of his love
[Music]
we have his love Thank You Mindy
from me Cher's hope will arise death is
defeated the king is alive
[Music]
[Applause]
is defeated
[Music]
you are the handle reaches out
I
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
especially in times like these Lord I'll
be asked for grace pray amen
hello everyone good evening grace in
peace it's really really good to be with
you all and welcome to the table and a
huge thank you to Mindy and Gary and
Noel I you know I was worshiping but I
did glanced at the comments and Noel was
clearly very popular in the comments
tonight I know I heard her during the
practice and I was like oh I can sing so
it's pretty it's pretty cool and it's
just um well one of the things I love
about this format that we're doing here
is that we are able to like include you
know kind of some different people like
last week we had Ryan and yeah it's just
it's it's pretty cool so I'm I am
grateful even in the midst of the
constraint of this technology on the
upside it is a huge blessing just to be
able to to do this and so thank you to
Gary again for helping us figure all
this technology stuff out and yeah
making it all kind of possible so I have
got two quick announcements because I
know obviously this is a pretty
unprecedented time in like us really in
a way world history but specifically US
history and and I know there you could
be in a place where you could just use
some connection like in your life and so
I want to offer you two ways to do that
I've mentioned these online I will
continue to mention them just because I
want to make sure that that no one like
slips through the cracks that we don't
get to the end of this thing and someone
just feels like no one was there for me
like that would be the worst and so we
have two ways first is just basically a
short like counseling listening prayer
time
with me I'm keeping my schedule as open
as possible specifically between 11 a.m.
and 2 p.m. on Tuesdays and Wednesdays so
that I can jump on like a
videoconference and just work phone call
and just be there with you for you
listen to you pray for you so um if
that's something you're interested in
email me at Brett that's the our ett
Brett at the table TX org I think Gary
might be putting that email address up
and yeah just reach out and don't I
don't know you might have the thought
like I don't really want to I don't want
to bother him or something well I'm
stuck at home okay so it would you would
be doing me and it would be my honor you
would help me fill my days with
something meaningful so feel free to
reach out the second way is meetups
these are our weekday small groups they
are continuing to meet basically online
and so we have everything from book
clubs to immense support groups to a
teen girls group and so if you're
interested in checking out a meet-up go
ahead and kick an email to Karen at the
table TX org she'll help you get
connected alright so this is part four
in our series titled tranquility
cultivating calm in a crazy world and
our big idea for this series is
basically that it's it's stress stress
from overwork from hurry from chronic
worry that lies at the root of so many
of just our modern ills surrounding
anxiety depression and just general
unhappiness um but but rather than kind
of framing the series in the negative
like how to attack depression or fight
anxiety we've been coming at it from a
more kind like a more positive spiritual
um kind of psychological soulful
perspective and I think that's you know
very much in keeping with our Christian
faith and so we've kind of been asking
instead of you know how do we fight
anxiety instead we've been asking how do
we cultivate the calm of Jesus Christ
and in a much earlier version of this
message this is version 3
I think we're all way too lengthy had to
cut something out but I had all these
examples of the calm of Jesus because if
you just go back and read the Gospels he
was what's the phrase cool as a cucumber
alright that's not a very cool way to
put it but it's true right like if you
just look great about Jesus he was just
calm I mean it was very difficult to get
him riled up occasionally prideful
religious folks really got his goat and
he would get upset
beyond that you just chill rice that's
kind of the question we've been asked
how do we cultivate the calm of Christ
how do we nurture tranquility in our
hearts in our minds and so with that in
mind I'm just so excited from a message
tonight because I really I just believe
if all you had was this one teaching um
you could in just a few weeks of
diligent practice massively positively
impact your baseline of tranquility and
joy I really believe it's that powerful
now having said that tonight will be
that unique in that I'll be referring to
a different religious tradition just a
few times throughout my sermon that
religious tradition is Buddhism now I
want to sort of just say this upfront
this is not because Pastor Brett is
considering it simply because so we have
a value here at the table for being an
eclectic people that's the word eclectic
and basically that means that we believe
all truth is God's truth no matter where
it may be found and I have simply found
a lot of truth in that tradition it has
helped illuminate my Christian practice
in a really meaningful way so okay
that's the caveat all right so with that
in mind the title of my message tonight
is present present and I want to frame
it kind of in this way so we live in the
age of worry of problem solving of
obsessive and endless thinking of almost
an addiction to like excite
and feeling we live in the age of more
accomplishing more becoming more doing
more as we looked at last week cramming
more in but is it possible that we are
missing the one thing required to
experience our lives as rich and yes at
times profoundly painful but also
impossibly beautiful as God saturated as
they actually are is it possible that
that for all of our knowledge and
technique and drive that we are missing
the one thing that actually makes life
worth living what is that one thing in
awareness that right now is all there is
like literally that is what God has
given you
right now the past is gone now we don't
treat it like it's gone but it is right
in the future is not yet here
all you and I ever have is right now and
yet we spend so much of our lives
distracted like lost in thought uneasy
you know that uneasiness that just sort
of haunts us we spend our days angry
about the past anxious about the future
especially right now it's very easy to
do right you might say that it's like
we're we're here without being here
there's this split between the mind in
the body right the body is here and this
is how Jesus put it in Matthew chapter 6
beginning in verse 25 he said therefore
I tell you do not worry about your life
what you'll eat or drink or about your
body what you will wear is not life more
than food and the body more than clothes
look at the birds of the air they do not
sow or
reap or store away in barns and yet your
heavenly Father feeds them are you not
much more valuable than they and can any
one of you by worrying at a single hour
to your life then verse 34 therefore do
not worry about tomorrow for tomorrow
will worry about itself each day has
enough trouble of its own all right so
what is the implication of this what is
Jesus saying well I think he's making
the observation that that us human
beings we human beings were strange
species because we spend most of our
lives not deeply immersed in the present
moment not mindful of ourselves our
environment the the people the beauty
around us know we spend our days like I
said here but not here right we spend
our days lost in thought about almost
anything but what we're actually doing
in other words we struggle to pay
attention to this day this hour this
moment right that's that's what Jesus is
saying like we're so often work into
tomorrow and we're missing today this
hour this moment and here's why I think
this matters I'm becoming increasingly
convinced that a lack of present moment
awareness is not only killing just start
so our inner sense of tranquillity but
it's also killing our faithfulness and
discipleship to Jesus Christ because as
I understand it the Christian life is a
process of learning to love learning to
develop a deep love for the sacred for
God learning to love every person we
interact with and yes even learning to
love and appreciate
it ourselves but here's the key question
how can I love if I am not present
wherever I am that this is the truth I
want us to start to get how can we love
if we are not present where we are I
want you to think of like your friends
or your partner or your kids what do
they want above all things I mean think
about it like you can give them gifts
right you can provide them with my super
fancy things in fact you can even spend
time with them but isn't it true that
what they're really after what they
crave is your presence I think of it
imagine that you go out on a date with
your significant other and you spend the
entire evening like you're there but
you're on your phone just where's my
phone I have a problem right so the
whole evening is spent like uh-huh
uh-huh yeah yeah mm-hmm now technically
you gave them time right I mean you were
there but would your partner say I feel
really connected I feel so connected you
this is just weird right no of course
not why because the primary way we love
is by giving the gift of our focused
attention and presence I've talked about
this before but my brother has this
amazing capacity to be present and it's
goodness I have a mic here and not my
foot a camera and so this is like if you
talk to my brother
this is how he looks at you like he's
just he's just locked in I mean and
there have been times where I'll like
walk over like hey buddy hey Josh hey
real quick
I said so a quick question kind of and
he will not break he will just ignore me
he's just he's just locked in right this
is this is how we we love well is giving
the gift that of our focused attention
in our presence and so for the last six
years I have been learning on a journey
trying to practice what I'll call um
I'll call it present moment awareness
and and I have good news in bad news
all right so the good news is that it is
indeed completely transformative like it
will draw you closer to God to yourself
to the people in your life now you will
be better everywhere across the board at
work at play at home everywhere okay now
the bad news bad news is that it is
indeed the hardest thing I have ever
attempted in my life I mean I said I've
been working on this six years and I'm
still a beginner and um I mean at one
level right it's a simple practice
simply focus your mind on the present
moment on what is right now
okay it's simple so that's you're having
a conversation with someone you're there
if you're working on something you're
there if you're walking you're there
right it's super simple not easy not
easy at all and depending on your
personality though I think it's not easy
for differing reasons in other words not
everyone kind of drifts out of the
present moment for the same reasons and
so let me give you I'm gonna give you
four types of people and why they
struggle to be mindful of the present
moment I suspect you'll recognize
yourself in at least one maybe two of
these maybe more all right but let me
let me go through these number one is
the Warriors are the Warriors not it's
plural are the Warriors not warriors
warriors so this is
who Jesus was speaking directly to in
our beginning text right from Matthew 6
when he said do not worry all right so
these are the people who are constantly
scanning the world for threats right
your mind is obsessed with what tomorrow
could hold and and like you were you are
weeks ahead of everyone on this you know
kovat coronavirus thing like you were oh
you you had him and this is and here's
the thing it's not even just for you um
like you're worried about everyone in
your life right your family friends
coworkers and in fact if they don't seem
worried you're worried that they aren't
worried enough um your real mess it's
okay we're all miss in our own way that
leads me to the second group this is my
group I'm gonna call them the thinkers
the thinkers um yeah this is definitely
me so for these folks life is a problem
to ponder a riddle to be solved you are
constantly mayor should say we are
constantly lost in thought right when
when we're driving when you're driving
it's like you're not driving you're
solving problems when you're talking
with someone like you're kind of
listening but mostly you're solving
their problems and thinking well you're
gonna say next and as far as you're
concerned honestly you don't even need a
body you just exist straight just from
right right here on up you all you need
is a brain just a brain to think and
think and think and think and think now
but the harsh truth is that this type
does not want to face um the fact that
there is a difference between thinking
about God and loving God there's a
difference between solving people's
problems and loving them there's a
difference between thinking about
yourself
in your life and analyzing it and
actually tuning in to your body in the
world in this present moment all right
the third type these are the feelers
these are the folks who aren't
necessarily um they're not so it's just
maybe worry doesn't quite get at it and
they aren't so much problem-solving so
much as they are sort of lost in a sea
of emotions and feelings sometimes
positive most of the time negative and
while on the surface right this might
seem great like oh good so good no
you're so tuned into your feelings
that's that's awesome oh the problem is
they take their feelings way too
seriously like they don't realize that
feelings are like the weather right they
come they go but for them whatever they
are feeling right now is reality itself
and they believe it will last forever
because you this feeling this is now the
truest thing about them and they don't
realize it but but this is actually
cloudy it's obscuring the reality of the
present moment because a feeling is just
a feeling it's not the totality of this
present moment right see they think
they're being present but actually
they're hijacked right their brain has
been hijacked by very strong emotions
and they need to calm down
detach a bit and realize that they in
this moment are more than simply what
they are feeling all right the fourth
type are the doers I thought about
calling them the achievers but honestly
that's not quite accurate because while
this can be sort of a very type a
hard-driving
you know person it can also simply be
the ones who just love to do things
right they wake up and they got stuff to
do and they get busy and by the way this
doesn't sound bad right um but it does
have its its dark side its shadow side
I'm Shana Nyquist in her book present
over perfect um she describes this
really really powerfully she writes many
of us myself included considered our
souls necessary collateral damage to get
done the things we felt we simply had to
get done because of other people's
expectations because we want to be known
as highly capable because we're trying
to outrun an inner emptiness and for a
while we don't even realize the
compromise we've made we're on autopilot
chugging through the day on fear and
caffeine checking things off the list
falling into bed without even a real
thought or feeling or connection all day
long just a sense of having made it
through that's a stunning word and you
can probably hear in that the the shadow
side of that kind of doer achiever mode
and in what's a little bit dangerous
about maybe this one is um American
culture in particular it really
celebrates the doer
um and but it but we have to realize who
we got to be careful right we have to be
wise with it now just to be clear um
none of these four types are bad like my
point is not evil how could you all
right they're not bad head of themselves
for example the worrier
at their best this simply someone who's
really great at threat
detection and they see problems
developing before others right at their
best they aren't worried as I said two
weeks ago just concerned hmm they have
concerns right concerns that hopefully
they can kind of identify and then take
action on and then move forward not
churning churning churning churning
right that's the danger all right but
the thinker who thinker is also not a
terrible person they're great at seeing
deeply and solving problems the feeler
is emotionally intuitive right very
tuned into their own feelings the
feelings of others they would make great
therapist and fabulous friends because I
can just sit with you and be like my
gosh right that I think it's wonderful
and we need the doers among us amen
someone's got to get something done and
so that's great but but what happens
what's not so great well as we've seen
each type has its own special way of
becoming detached from this present
moment which is to say detached from God
detached from even their true selves
that's what Shona Nyquist named so
beautifully in that quote right you can
hear the person who's just hard-charging
or going going and yet hey haven't been
tuned in right that the worrier is eaten
up with anxiety the the thinker has
turned into a robot the feeler has
become a basket case the doer is a
perpetual motion machine and when I slip
into these modes the life of Christ is
not happening in me joy is not bubbling
up tranquility is not becoming the
defining marker of my life I am I'm
failing to learn to love all right so
what can we do I definitely don't want
just end there well good luck so let me
give you I'm gonna give you a few
practices will do two practices that can
basically just help you grow in your
awareness of the present moment so here
they are number one when walking walk
when sipping coffee just sip
I know super profound like I said
earlier super simple simple not easy
this is a short story this is from the
Zen Buddhist tradition and it says a
certain Zen master was approached by
disciple who asked about the essentials
of the teaching probably expecting to
receive a very lengthy exposition of
subtle Buddhist philosophy or perhaps
something marvelous in mysterious he got
neither the Zen master only said when
hungry I eat when tired I sleep the
disappointed disciple asked but this is
what ordinary people do how do you
differ to which the Zen master replied
when they eat most people think a
thousand thoughts and when they sleep
they dream a thousand dreams so what
does this mean it what it may mean is
that most people aren't very mindful
right since they allow their minds to
simply wander around wherever they
please and then even worse they believe
what they're thinking like oh my god
that's the last thing you wanna do this
believe every thought that comes into
your head like it's a recipe for deep
sadness right whereas the spiritually
minded person how are they they're
concentrated they're tuned in to
whatever or whoever is before them so
how does this look in my own personal
life what it means is that you'll often
find me right I said these last six
years I've been trying to do this um
you're often finally doing one thing at
a time
often not always but often when I've run
I just run no music no podcasts until
the shutdown recently I used to have a
commute to my part-time job in Dallas
you know before the whole pandemic and
it took me about 45 minutes and at least
one time a day either coming or going I
would just drive no radio no podcasts
just me my breathing tuning in tuning
into the presence of God and generating
a sense of peace a sense of joy and
honestly here's what I noticed on the
days that I had the podcast going and
this has been true for years now um I do
not deal well with traffic because I'm
already in a distracted state but when
I'm driving and I'm just driving all of
a sudden traffic he's not a problem it's
just some extra time to enjoy driving so
what does this mean for your life here's
maybe away at sum it up this means more
mono tasking less multitasking right
mono meaning one one tasking solo task
more mono tasking less multitasking
right so when you're cooking just cook
when you're pushing your kiddo on the
swing just push them right don't read
articles on your phone while you're
trying to push your get on this way all
right it means just just do the one
thing simply be present again is this
hard and challenging to do yes
especially at first but over time you'll
learn in your connection to yourself
your connection to Christ you're tuned
in this to others I promise you it will
skyrocket simply be present all right so
that's the first point point number two
is sit in Sylar
every day think of this like the
difference between drinking lemonade and
taking a shot of pure lemon juice
practice number one the point number I
just gave you that's like that's the
lemonade it's more diluted but you know
it sort of goes down easier practice
number two this one this is a very
highly concentrated form of number one
because like if you think about it it's
actually it's the same thing points
number one and number two are the same
thing right you're becoming aware of
yourself and god you're coming back to
the present moment but in point number
two you're you're reducing all external
sensory perceptions right so often when
you think of someone in silence like in
a sort of meditative form of Prayer
prayer of quiet what what are they doing
right they're closing their eyes right
there they're getting in a quiet place
where right there's nothing coming into
ears they're stopping movement right so
they're not walking around and trying to
get things done it's it's sort of it's a
stop it's a shutting down an external
sensory perception and this is your
spiritual shot of lemon juice now the
way I drink my lemon juice is via a
Christian form of meditation it's called
centering prayer from father Thomas
Keating um he was Christian monk god
rest his soul he just passed away a few
years ago and um you can google him
Thomas Keating centering prayer and it's
it's an incredibly powerful form of
Prayer because it's just simply a time
to sit and be present to yourself in God
no distractions I mean nothing and again
super simple just sit in silence but not
easy right however over time it does get
easier and you'll actually start to look
forward to this time of concentrated
presence and also by taking your shot of
lemon juice
each morning or evening however you like
to do it we're both it makes drinking
your lemonade throughout the day feel
much easier so if you're wondering what
does brit-brats day look like um this is
how my day always begins wake up brush
the teeth sit my booty down in quiet for
quite a while and it's just a powerful
way of coming home to myself and to God
all right so in closing I'm gonna offer
one clarifying point and then a few
resources so the clarifying point is
that I just want a name I'm not
suggesting that you stop reading your
Bible or saying regular prayers
I still do both of those each day right
I'm simply naming that I think we should
incorporate these practices as well
particularly if you're you find yourself
struggling with anxiety depression just
a general sense of unhappiness oh man I
encourage you to engage these resources
and engage these practices alright so
here are three books that I found really
helpful in learning about this also if
you're not a book reader you can just
look on these for these people on
YouTube and you'll find lots of videos
and resources about them so book number
one is the heart of centering prayer by
Cynthia bore goal and that it teaches
you that centering prayer practice that
I was describing earlier the second book
is the practice of the presence of God
by brother Lawrence this is a must read
every Christian must read this book it's
super small super easy read and then
finally peace is every step this is by
the Buddhist monk tick not Han and he's
he's amazing if you if you want to learn
that kind of day-to-day present moment
awareness
you need to read tick not Han pieces
every step a true Saint in our world
wonderful wonderful so alright let me go
ahead and pray for us Lord Jesus would
you would you teach us Lord to be
present
because when we're not present God were
not connected to you
and I pray over every person listening
to this talk whether they're a part of
our church the table or not I pray that
you would leave them into a new path of
awareness of awareness of who they are
and the beauty around them and most of
all God an awareness of you that you are
closer than the air we're breathing now
that you love us in the world all things
and all people and God bring us into an
awareness that the living reality that
we want to touch that reality in that
truth so would you do that work in our
hearts and minds make us spiritually
minded people not just people who know a
bunch of things not just a bunch of
people who know things about the Bible
or about Christian faith but people who
practice your presence who are in tune
with the risen Christ so we love you
Lord it's the name of Jesus I pray
[Music]
[Applause]
I was useless you lifted high in your
mercy outside oh this mind
[Music]
[Applause]
well my friends thank you so much for
joining us so we are going to hang out a
little bit for a little bit longer me
and Mindy and I've heard that it might
be possible for Gary to post a link and
we could even maybe cycle in a few of
you into this so we could like chat so
feel free to leave comments and ask
questions or however you'd like to
engage whether it's something about the
service or just otherwise we'd love to
yeah just connect with you for a little
while so that would be happening right
for this so let me go ahead and send
those of you who need to go off with
this you are God's servants you're
gifted with drinks you're gifted with
visions and upon you rest the grace of
God like flames of fire go love serve
the Lord in a strength of the Spirit
gabi with you all have a great great
week
and scene so yeah the links out there
guys on the Facebook page and when you
go ahead and click on that if you would
be helpful if you where had some
headphones and make sure you enter your
name if you get in you have to also go
into your name at the center so yeah
this is a toe experiment so bear with
this I'm not sure if anybody has tried
yet I saw any sane of very convicting
for this multitasking silence fearing
mom of three sister right here yeah it
really is it's it's the craziest thing
you would think this would be the
easiest thing in the world like what
just be where you are man but our minds
they're a mess I mean yeah I'm gonna get
too nerdy into the science of it but
it's I think some of it is just how
we've come about like in this world that
you know our our ancestors were had to
survive and in really dangerous world so
their threat detection centers were like
going crazy you know because all the
chilled out people died the saber-tooth
Tigers got him you know their dislike oh
it's all gonna work out no well you know
like people who were aware and you know
worried worrying thinking of the future
thinking okay what could happen
contingency planning to do I mean that
was the world right and it's crazy
though because now we're well aside from
this pandemic all things considered were
quite safe I mean there's no saber-tooth
Tigers I go on a run I'm not like
furtively looking around wondering is an
animal going to eat me I don't worry I
don't have to worry about that but
where's my mind it's like endless you
know it'll find some problem
be wildly concerned about even though
it's not life or death I'll be fine but
my brain doesn't really like that so
yeah I hear ya yeah Brett I wasn't been
wondering if like you could speak at all
- I was thinking about how for me
whenever I am just like pres trying to
be present the moment like just sip your
coffee I feel lazy like it's actually
for me I'm running from this fear that
I'm being lazy hmm yeah that's maybe uh
right try again I'm guessing you're type
number for the doer and it's yeah it's
probably something where you well it's
it's a little bit cliche but that whole
thing like you're a human being not a
human doing and we really yeah there's
something in certain people and but it's
kind of in the culture to where you
derive your value from getting stuff
done and instead of you are already
valuable even if you never did another
thing like you're loved you're enough
yeah and sitting with that and learning
to become comfortable with that
that seems yeah again important but so
challenging hard work yeah
really challenging yeah CJ's just got to
worry about the Bobcats Katelyn and
Brandon oh my gosh y'all are Palin
you're totally like here and talking are
you you're recovered enough from your
was a strep yeah I still have it but it
is much better and I can breathe again
so yeah yeah it's well I'm so glad that
you're yeah like on the road to recovery
Hey
Hey who else just joined us muted oh
yeah you're muted I'm so glad that
you're yeah like on the road be recovery
hey hey let's just joined us this is
Johnson North Fort Worth awesome would
you say your first name Jamie I'm so
glad the year this is yeah on the road
dear country I know
awesome would you say your first name on
the road Gary let me jump out and commit
let's just join this would you say yeah
it seems like it stopped looking
hopefully Brett will jump again
yep I'm wondering Brandon and Caitlin
are either of you like what personality
all connected with if you love more be a
doer and sometimes a thinker
yeah I feel er I feel everything all the
time yeah controls that y'all down with
each other out yes Jamie how about you I
am a thinker and a doer
more recently definitely a feeler wow
you're kind of kind of growing into that
side like it got out of control at one
point in time oh yeah well can probably
speak to that
- she might know a thing or two about
one a new hormonal change no learning to
deal with high levels of one hormone and
let no levels of the other yeah
changed me upside down and backwards
yeah yeah I can only imagine that would
be really challenging good thing I had a
nice psychiatrist following along with
me
[Music]
Caitlin what have you found anything
that's kind of helped you like like when
you get in that deeply feeling place and
just starting to go like wild have you
found any either practices or certain
things that help you like kind of
recenter and find God and yourself and
all that again um I mean a lot of it has
to do with what you said just like
trying you just have to like like come
you just have to focus your mind and
become present because that's what
happens is like you get too far into
your mind and too far into your emotions
and you just have to like you just have
to like shift your focus from up
here to down here and they're like
what's right in front of you
I feel like centering or like what is it
grounding yeah grounding so you know
things you can see things you can hear
things you can touch things you can
smell or something you can taste just to
kind of ground you that also helps -
yeah yeah yeah it's awesome Thank You
Jamie how about you did have you found
anything that's kind of helped you
recenter I look great in mind I haven't
heard of this one who wrote it in days
this was handed to me by my psychologist
and because she knows I'm a thinker and
I ripped through this book in a week and
a half not that small of a book but
still it's about getting outside of that
constantly running around in your head
my
and literally stand side is almost a
third party looking at yourself and just
in that mind and to diffuse that's his
magic we're diffusing those thought
processes where you can you can step
aside and not let them consume you
you're not in the thought process you're
watching it and so now you have more MO
and you're creating what's called a
flexible mind and let me tell you it's
brand-new it easy yeah yeah yeah that's
that's yeah there's a term I've heard I
got this but it was something about the
idea of being The Watcher like sort of
its but kinda what you're describing
like step back a little bit and just
notice what's happening to you like oh
my gosh my heart is beating out of my
chest oh my gosh my hands are feeling
sweaty you know or like I am I am really
freaking out you know or I'm really
feeling and then what are you feeling
I'm feeling afraid I'm feeling this I'm
feeling I'm and it's sort of like in
name is somehow you just get a little
critical distance and that can help you
like ah that's what's going on you know
like even thinking back to Mindy when
you earlier mentioned like I feel guilty
I thought you know I try to just sit and
just I'm just gonna sit my coffee I'm
just gonna sit here and enjoy myself you
know but even noticing huh look at me
I'm feeling guilty for just sitting here
like just enjoy it that's what's you
know in in becoming aware and then
there's like good now it's like there's
the true self and then you're you're
recognizing the false self in a way that
gets kind of it's doing its crazy thing
and you're like look at me that is nuts
you know and not quite that judge you
good yeah so I wanted to hop in
yeah effort for me it's uh I I become
the doer to avoid the worrier
you know yeah what I end up doing just
otherwise yeah I'm the guy laying in bed
at night worrying about you know what
there is to do or what I can't do about
certain things and so it's tough this is
a very timely message Thank You Brett
and yeah yeah it's very hard to sit in
silence you know I've been trying to do
it and like I have a a Bible reading
buddy right now and
we committed to testing each other every
day about when we finished our our quiet
time in our passages and I've failed a
couple times now you know and had to
double up on a few days because it's
super hard to stop moving for me because
when I stopped moving I have to be with
my thoughts and it's kind of tough right
now yeah yeah I like how you put it I
become the doer to avoid the warrior and
yeah we do kind of we'll switch around
like you know depending on what I need
to try to compensate but sometimes it's
sort of changing out one unhealthy like
maybe even the way people do this with
addiction I mean I do this with addition
like switch out my addictions you know
so this week it's sugar next week
who knows whatever like and it's yeah we
almost can kind of rotate through so
Gary do we have anyone else trying to
get in or can we just keep chatting I
think we have CJ trying to get in but
you might be coming on just now we'll
see here in a moment we have butter
Black's of six hi guys and welcome thank
you thank you how is everyone great this
is Kaitlyn and Brandon in one window
which you might recognize them inside
you Jamie I just met and you know
everyone else in my dear Mindy yes yes
yes Fran good to see your face
thank you thank you good to see you guys
this being separated and not being able
to come together is kind of trying right
now yeah it's
it's not good for people that don't need
to be isolated yes and I think it's the
challenge too is the length of time I
mean oh the one thing I like everyone we
have to take a week right it's like okay
we'll all get over it and we'll be fine
but you know jeez three weeks four weeks
lucky in CB insight
and I know being an introvert I was very
excited that I was forced to stay home
but now it's kind of like I kind of want
to get out right yeah yeah Jamie how
about you are you like more introverted
or extroverted or what do you wear
Deaton I'm still on the fence on what
what when I was on introvert all hiding
from everybody and doing my own thing
and I'm asking a huge amount of
knowledge in my industry as you can see
behind me do well and then somewhere
along the line switch flipped but is
sharing all that watching out me gushing
out no I hang out CAD design and so I
turned into an extrovert at the same
time internally I feel where I don't
have to be around a bunch of people but
death luxury that that they laugh yeah
yeah I know for me like i like i come
home and i recharge my energy but then i
need somewhere to put that energy some
time and being around people sometimes
helps like get that energy out
I'm very well recharged I think issue
I'm like overcharged right now see I
felt the same way for let's say the week
before less cuz ever we were all on
spring break so I was at home well then
school shut it down
and it's like wait a minute
I need to go back to work right but now
we're feeding kids so it's it's okay I'm
able to go back to work and at least
reconnect with some of my students so oh
yeah that's true they they kind of do
the drive-through and I'll give a meal
and that's beautiful yeah they're doing
the same thing in my kids school
district garland iced tea because we
have a you know a lot of folks in need
of that like that's that's an important
meal for them so you know in something
I've noticed about
idabelle I mean I've heard a lot about
Idaho before I even moved here but I
didn't realize how poverty it was mm-hmm
so being out in the neighborhoods and
feeding these kids literally off the
back of a box truck don't laugh but you
see the home life yeah in it it takes
you a home to a whole different place
it's it's amazing it's amazing and then
it just reconfirms that these kids
really need to be in school like that's
their safe place because home is not
their safe place yeah well that's a
great that's a tremendous insight man
yeah you take with you back into your
life you know like once everything
absolutely where you'll have a new
appreciation new insight into people
that's especially growing up in
reliquary a-- and then this town being
literally like South Dallas Pleasant
Grove yeah you know it's just totally
different for me different mm-hmm I'm
gonna get in the chat we're gonna go
ahead and drop so it's Andy how are you
I'm good good good this is CJ and the
green shirt Jamie and it looks like a
black and then you know Mindy so good to
see ya
Andy's been churning out the what it was
called
quarantine cabarets or something like
that were you saying you do covers songs
he's turning them out like crazy
oh yeah that's pretty great
that there's a Facebook group that's
called quarantine karaoke mm-hmm really
I think yeah some amazing singers and
that one and it is so how bored people
are like yeah yeah especially in the
arts industry which isn't really the
most thriving industry right right
so yeah you need a creative outlet yeah
we need yeah we're performing we need we
need to create about yes it's so so
great Andy did you were you able to
listen to the message or did you just
jump on lap I just got on okay cool I
was gonna ask you about it but no no no
worries yeah it's on things you and I
have talked about something like yeah
being in the present moment we actually
have just a few weeks ago and you know
we're talking about a great anti-anxiety
breathing routine have you all heard of
box breathing mm-hmm so it's called box
cuz the idea is basically it's like four
four four four so it's in four four
counts whole four four counts out for
four counts and then you hold that
nothing you know empty lungs four counts
and it is an incredibly powerful
anti-anxiety breathing like I'll do it
at night like you ever wake up and
you're just like and you're kind of a
wake and it's something that something
happened it's just your mind you know
it's churning with whatever and that
it's I'll do it and it's immensely
helpful for like getting back to sleep
or if I'm like before like a speaking
thing or I don't know just a hard
conversation I'll do it in my car and
it's really powerful like it's amazing
how the breath influences the mind and
the body and all that it's yeah it's
really really great I'm gonna have to
try that because yeah I mean new
technique
Thanks hmm yeah box breathing he's gonna
try it I'm gonna try it well guys I love
you I'm gonna go get me some dinner I
just wanted to pop in and tell you all
hello it's great that we're meeting this
way love you man
good to see you love y'all yeah well I'm
probably gonna take off too because I've
got things to clean nose watching all of
your previous lessons online I'm the one
that's right out of you Oh
keep tuning in thank you very much all
right there he goes
all right my friend guys real good cool
thank you so much and yeah all right
peace up all right I get